yeah yeah we go six chocolate bar said I
got duped into buying in a bar when a
Girl Scout came into the bar and asked
me if I wanted to buy chocolate from her
and I I said yes she said five for 20 I
said okay
she gave me six I didn't know who was in
the wrong her parents her not being
there and letting her just wander into a
bar or me for being an easy target no
here we go I'm just kind of running on
empty right now which is why I need body
fuel I asked you guys last time about a
possible name for this series okay maybe
I'll put a couple of my favorites for
this cooking series name on my Instagram
story and then you guys can vote on the
one that you want from there because I'm
a Libra I'm wildly indecisive making
this decision on my own don't want to do
it but I want to do is make a goddamn
burger and shove it into my mouth pull
this looks great melty Monterey Jack
burger here we go plan we got our bag of
ingredients I just got excited every
time I do one of these helen french
videos I get excited because this is a
little treasure chest that becomes like
a little a thing from a paper bag to a
porcelain throne [ __ ] let's do it and
let the bag sit outside a little too
long so it's a little bit honestly
humblebrag told me always should be a
little wet Oh
random people watch these videos 150 200
brush like I said is a service it
delivers these meals with all of the
ingredients without excess and then they
give you these recipe cards that have
six steps with visuals as well as oh my
god I got dumb words literary eels if we
know anything from last month's episode
the pictures are great for the people
that follow the pictures sometimes I
don't follow the pictures I get ahead of
myself and yeah hope they're not great
oh yeah this series is an opportunity
for me to connect if you really relate
to you
where are Greta been a couple weeks more
or less mm-hmm are you doing I regret
starting to make this video or and I
feel crazy but we are only with it
then yes to this distress we need to
preheat our oven to 400 degrees or 50
degrees and we need to wash and dry all
of our produce we just have to wash the
most valid one we need to mince one
clove of garlic
Hot Cross Buns rosy impression of
opportunity Rome mince and garlic here
we go Wow peel and thinly sliced this
red onion and we call it a red onion
when it's very clearly purple it's the
same way that like why did they let
Teletubbies be a show cut zucchini into
three inch long pieces than have each
piece lengthwise that halves into thin
wedges what I did not retain anything
that I just red or purple I think that's
what we're supposed to do one thing
about cooking is never feeling secure
always feeling slightly bamboozled you
know an edible escape room it's up to
you to get out what you want from it I
guess I've never done the escape room I
don't know I wanna step - we're gonna
make the garlic mayo and a small bow you
seem fatigued we're gonna combine two
tablespoons of mayonnaise oh your sex Oh
what was it turned on by a substance
that's neither a solid or a liquid ah
there we go and then we had as much
garlic as we like I'm gonna chop this up
a little bit more make it into like more
of a pace that some of our garlic goes
in and salt and pepper and then you guys
party with each other brave brave right
oh just like fire fest very white and
not appealing to look at on to step
three we're gonna make some onion jam
that sounds nuts alternate camera angle
initiate he's a drizzle of oil and a
large pan over medium heat add onion and
cook stirring occasionally until
caramelized eight to ten minutes all
right let them go to nuts and then we're
gonna stir in some vinegar and a
teaspoon of sugar it's all we pepper
until it gets jammy for another one to
two minutes and then we're gonna remove
it from the heat and put it aside in a
small bowl all the onion cooks in a
medium bowl we're gonna combine the
zucchini Oh
zucchini that's fun cinema party didn't
pace itself we're gonna add 1/2 tbsp of
the garlic mayo I'm gonna get gross I'm
gonna use my hands oh my god if you ever
want a physical sensation that's not
desirable put some mayonnaise on some
zucchini with your hands uh this is
anyone's fetish directly off then we're
gonna add 1/4 cup of panko bread crumbs
on the 2 tablespoons of oregano and salt
and pepper and then we toss it with our
hands again so you're gonna take our
baking sheet but some olive oil all over
it we're gonna put these guys on the
baking sheet put them in the oven for
like 15 minutes we're gonna toss them
around halfway through get on there yeah
weird okay wait crusty zucchini I mean
that's a great drag name crusty zucchini
hell yeah
and now we're going to work on our B
where's the beef great question it's in
the fridge oh how are you how are you
guys more regrets less regrets and
slawsa ass
that's handle we're all me oh we can't
move on to our burger patties until we
finish her onions
turns out I turned out when you read the
directions in full before you start it
helps you in the process of making who
knew literally no one a lot of you guys
have asked about vegetarian recipes
coming up now that I'm doing these
cooking videos more regularly and I
really want to make that happen because
hellofresh offers three plans to choose
from family but classic and veggie and
you can switch up whenever you want
depending on when you taste changes oh I
need your burning what's Shrek's
favorite spotify playlist onion jam okay
I don't think I made a jam tries to get
jammy I'm gonna shakers rapini a little
bit take that for whatever the
gifts this got jammy I think I did it
wrong anyway we gotta take this out of
the pan and put it to the side because
we're gonna cook our burgers in the same
yeah yeah take our beat I'm we're gonna
separate into two patties break this
into two patties wash your hands anybody
give me is a slimy mother stays it was
something that bird put in your pan for
three to five minutes each side here we
go oh okay daddy's in the pan cavities
are in the pan three to five minutes
each side season with salt and pepper
now we're gonna check our zucchini just
bud so I think we might need to take
that out now they have mayhem I forgot
to check in with you how are you got
family problems cool bike the mountain
detail in the comments section below now
back to ignoring you on the personal
level Oh zucchini can go over a little
bit longer it doesn't look good up my
grandpa this bake up I'm watching my
bake right now I like this kitchen and
then I think right now what's going on
what do I need to do
hey hey I'm gonna do a sexy ad read so
if you could just hold your boner for
one second that's what we were talking
about you can get season off what you
can get
seasonal simple recipes with
pre-measured ingredients
delivered right to your door the great
thing about cooking is say you get the
opportunity to have an existential
crisis at any point while it's happening
because it seems like a very reputed
wonderful thing and then somehow becomes
like a big
my meat has been cooked three to five
minutes on each side now I need to get
my hand-eye coordination together I'm
gonna cover them with Monterey Jack
cheese I'm gonna cover them with a
tangible thing that keeps the heat
inside and cook them for one minute
until the cheese melts from supposed to
toast the bunch yeah this recipe says
that we should put this on another paper
pan and put it in the oven toast them up
I don't want to do it I'm not gonna do
it just like blasting so now let's put
these burgers together and see what we
got we have our buns we're gonna put
some of our garlic mayo they gave us
some ketchup to put on Oh
double damn look he's got damn burrs on
oh my god onion quote Jam on okay put
more ketchup on cuz I can and I'm
allowed Oh me oh you kidding me everyone
look clean and normal and nice amazing
okay hold on I gotta get Beauty shots
with my other camera
[Music]
darah uh who wore it best
Oh so what thank you again hello fresh
for sponsoring this video and this
series of videos throughout the year if
you guys want to sign up for hello fresh
you can get eight free meals in your
first month that's $80 off your what
eight free meals $80 off your first
month by going to hello fresh calm and
using the coupon code grace helbig 80
that's right grace helbig 88 free meals
come on here we go baby this is the
moment we've all been waiting for
also hello fresh is now from $6.99 per
serving oh no again I just gotta breath
for this service to give me the
disillusion sense that I'm good at
cooking yeah but also I never stop
supporting me oh my god that's so good
bingo guys there's another cooking video
for you if you like this let me know in
the comments down below give this video
a thumbs up I know it on my face you
actually seen your face I've been
recording for so long that literally my
camera just turned off so other than
that I don't know how do I want my beef
between my buns and that's disgusting
and I hate myself for doing that